hey youtubers
it's charles is going to be my star wars:
rebels breaking ranks review
it's either like episode 4 or 5, the numbering is a little bit messed up
technically I think it's
episode 4
if you felt like there was some story
missing basically what they did is they
picked up
in the middle the action and then cut
away to dialogue to explain what was
going on
think at this 22-minute episode is like
a 30-minute episode
to the just started eight minutes in
careful responders if you haven't seen
the episode yet
starting with top I moment number five
is rejoins the Imperial Academy
they're still on with all which i think
is interesting
you think the Imperial Academy would be
somewhere bigger but the Empire's past
so of course they have satellite schools
in the outer rim
in terms our galactic geography because
pretty far away from course on
which is where we spent most the time
during the prequels and during the Clone
Wars
you the clone work I travel all around
as long as we get to see new locations
in load all like the Imperial cat in
this episode I'm totally happy I totally
don't mind them sticking to that planet
a cursory examination as some other
things the academy as well as their
security measures
raise a few issues that I'll just talk
about as I get to the video
the reason he join the Academy was to
get the decryption cards they could find
the location
at the shipment of Khyber crystals
number four as replaced by game
setting expectations low because as a is
fairly new
it was fun to watch him try to be a
badass
it's also a nice twist on the idea
that's it infiltrator
he's like a jet I'd trainee infiltrator
using the forced to get information
the friend that stayed behind at the end
to find his sister actually that the
esther was gonna try and control his
mind
whenever he caught him in the middle the
episode trying to break into the office
the kids stayed at the academy so if he
stays on and becomes a stormtrooper
arguably israel will have the easiest
time in the world controlling is mine
storm troopers have the week is mine in
the galaxy
when my first rehab survey shins
calloused does not like getting
unexpected packages
he does not like free things if they
played the scene for comedy
humidity's been like oh yes I will
totally take this free package that I
definitely did not order
it does make you wonder what the key
would have done if callace had accepted
the package
if you'd like the ones by school stop if
you gonna give someone a big package
bring you think package the you can give
it to them number three
as restoring trooper training is like a
cross between the Star Trek holiday
in Mega Man it was fun to watch as rare
run circles around everyone
the staff thought that it was fishy that
he was so good either going to do
something more that needed to use the
Inquisitor but he didn't show up till
the end
as kinda hoping that he'd walk out on
deck and see as Ryan oh hell would break
loose
I feel like they may just a little too
easy in the didn't really deliver on the
promise a bit being super hard I mean
elected by the platforms eventually
but there is no threat level to Ezra so
it feels like there's no stakes
when you hear stories about the Imperial
Academy usually it's
really grand really pure something in
this just did not feel like it
maybe that's just the flagship schools
were talking about in the core world's
speaking about storm troopers to and a
lot of people are wondering
what's going on with the clone troopers
in with the normal troopers
at a certain point in the Empire's wrote
stop making new clones is no clones
anymore
most the night off during the wars so
now we're in the initial days
them recruiting actual people like the
actually have to recruit people again
the key just magic up new forces
overnight
and even did take a while to grow new
clones number two
the big space battle so we found out
what happens when you don't need a shift
in the process and entering hyperspace
I think the explosion was extra big just
because all the Khyber crystals on board
a lot in the Star Wars visual media
doesn't do a really good job explaining
the mechanics
hyperspace is a couple different ways
explain faster than light travel
there's wormholes in their subspace and
I think subspace
is the one that Star Wars uses I tried
to hold Star Wars is science against ed
is not a show that promises to explain a
lot of things end up like that
especially if it's an animated show for
children like rebels is
if any had a really detailed
understanding of the mechanics
at Star Wars hyperspace just feel free
to read below in the comments
the whole Kabir crystal plotline was one
of my complaint to the episode
in it really didn't explain what was
going on very well
like all the cutaways with the
exposition didn't really make up for the
fact that there are so many scenes
missing
clearly is a very important mission
paper crystals are very big deal
if you have a real under the expanded
here are the comics the going to cover
crystals
therefore strongly localize to very
specific places in the galaxy
the increase the power of or sensitive
people a thousand times over
so if the empire with shipping them
around the inquisitors could use them to
become
much much more powerful so if you cried
a little bit when they blew them all up
they were just trying to keep them outta
the hands of the enemy I suppose we can
forgive them that
even though keenan in israel could have
a whole lotta fun even with just one
crystal
note to self next time before blowing up
cover crystals
snag one in whenever one moment as rub
breaks out at the academy
best you seven a TST ever I think there
was an 80 as teen
the sea water but Walker's is a general
term for 80 80 80 St
any derivative type a transport like
that as much fun as it was watching them
crashed their way at the academy there's
that couple issues
that I have to raise first of the two
commanders worst commuters
in history the Academy what this is all
going on they're basically just standing
there yelling at people
you think that one of them would pick up
a blaster and start firing
and getting the comment on is working in
the outer rim territories
as an instructor because he's not that
great given the way things ended
I would think the inquisitors pride is
gonna kill 'em after this episode
to see nothing what's going to happen to
that kid did stay behind to
I don't think that he's for sensitive
but the inquisitors probably going to
train him
complained of having to fight as related
in the season either that or he lined up
on a milk carton like his sister
as much as they shied away from violence
during the training scenes
the show does have a lot of implied by
Linz like for instance whenever they
were in the typewriter battle
the book although ships think about how
many people were on those ships
been thinking about with the Inquisitor
is going to do to the commandant is what
that will look in
very dark stuff even if they don't show
it if you like in not having the
characters
address those deaths the show is missing
out there's a lot of Dexter dramatic
where you can have
killing people is bad even if they are
Imperials
let me know that what was your favorite
moment from the episode and what do you
think is going to happen to as rich
friend the Inquisitor took
overall I give the episode a B-minus is
because if you like it didn't have any
kind a dramatic tension
if you look at still using a lot of the
stories to set up bigger plots
type for instance when they take in
hiding he's actually played by Dante
Basco
whose you go from Avatar The Last
Airbender sup if there any Last
Airbender fans out there
I'm sure you prolly pick that up but I
feel like they wouldn't cast
bigger actors from love the sidewalls if
they weren't intending on during the
characters into something bigger
I think my only real complaint against
the episode though was just how easy it
was for them to infiltrate the Imperial
Academy
the episode really ends up being just
about putting your trust in other people
even though jack completely forgives as
rough for dicking over halfway through
the episode
if this were Ender's Game that would be
like the beginning a blood feud
I suppose that's another reference you
could draw this episode the pure Academy
is a little bit like Ender's Game
all in all it was entertaining episode
fund is the inside an hero Academy
little disappointing in the execution
next week as
prophesied is a hero's sabine episode I
think you when my previous videos I
mention how they basically had no
springtime at all
to surprise surprise they get the
headline episode together right now
they're actually to the more interesting
characters I'm actually pretty excited
about that
be sure to subscribe to my video be sure
to post the next week there are a couple
shows that are on break this week just
because the midterm elections
but there's no flash no reason to shield
but there is a row tomorrow so I will be
december is P is the next couple days
there is a marvel special tonight is
called marble 75th anniversary
saw be doing a video for that too in the
meantime you can click here for my last
start was rebels video
in you can click here to learn all about
Marvel's phase 3
thank you so much for watching so hyper
I'll see you guys tonight
it
good